[موسيقى]
التسجيل كانت هذه اصوات
وعندما تصل هذه
[موسيقى]
القياده العامه
اتذكر انني كنت مرتبكه كان الوقت مبكرا
جدا سالت زوجي ما هذا سمعت دولي انفجارات
بالفعل قال لي كلمه واحده لقد بدات
فعندما ترغب اوكرانيا بالانضمام الى
النيتو ذلك يعد استفزازا واضحا لان
التهديد في روسيا وعندما تستفز فانك تحصل
على النتائج السيئه
في حياه محدده هل هناك تهديدات هل هناك
مؤشرات على شيء
الاشخاص الذين حاولوا اغتيال يتولون الان
مناصب في السلطه ثلاثه منهم سيكررون
المحاوله مجددا
[موسيقى]
اللي خلى الميليشيات والمجموعات المسلحه
موجوده بهذا الشكل اللي هي سببين اولا
الصراع والانقسام اللي كان العوده للقضايا
وبالعوده دعوه التحقيق مع خبرتك اخر قضيه
قبل